today we will be explaining all attack
titans in the history of attack on titan
and we are sure there are some titans
you didn't know about let's start first
on the list of attack titans is no other
than aaron krueger kruger was born into
an ldn family living in marley his
father had joined an elden revolutionary
army led by the remnants of the royal
fritz family who remained on the
mainland unfortunately the army was very
ineffective and its members including
kruger's father were captured and burned
alive by the public security authorities
as kruger hid in the closet some time
later krueger was able to join the
marley government as a spy as a spy in
the military kruger would refer to
himself as the owl all while spending
his military career turning thousands of
aldians into titans over the years in
order to hide his identity two years
after the incident with grisha and fey
krueger inherited the power of the
attack titan from an unknown predecessor
gaining the power of the titans thirteen
years after inheriting his power when
the curse of ymir was beginning to take
hold of his health krueger was present
when grisha was tortured by the marley
officers he asked if he confessed the
owl's identity and grisha assured he did
not know krueger escorts grisha to the
top of a 30-foot wall telling grisha
that as punishment for treason he will
be transformed into a titan grisha tells
kruger that he remembers him from all
those years back when his sister was
murdered with krueger emotionlessly
acknowledging this he also calmly
watched the restorationists being turned
into mindless titans and chased after
their comrade when gross was about to
throw grisha off the wall krueger
suddenly intervened and pushed his
comrade off the wall and revealed to a
shocked grisha that he was in fact the
owl krueger set grisha free and answered
all the questions of the latter
justifying his deeds and telling him
about his life before letting a
determined grisha inherit his ability in
order to fulfill the elderly
restorationist's goal kruger revealed
the name of the titan he would become
and explain the history of the founding
titan and king fritz's vow with the
founding titan renouncing all war as he
prepared to inject grisha with a titan
serum he urged him to find a family and
complete his mission afterwards krueger
willingly allows himself to be eaten by
grisha successfully transferring the
attack titan to him we are sure you all
knew about kruger but stick with us till
the end when we will be explaining some
of the more mysterious attack titans
anyway this leads us into our next
attack titan user grisha jaeger grisha
was born on liberia in the continent of
marley he was an aldean doctor and a
member of the elder restorationist
movement after zeke exposed his family
and all the restorationists they were
sentenced to go to paradise island as
pure titans he was saved by aaron
krueger and he also inherited his titan
powers after mysteriously showing up
outside walmaria he was found by keith
shadis grisha claimed to have suffered
amnesia and he had no memories about the
civilization inside the walls in the
military after he successfully
infiltrated inside of the walls he
started the family and had a son he
named aaron grisha used his occupation
as a doctor to get close with government
officials in order to gather some
information on the ruler of the walls he
eventually discovered the location of
the reese family's chapel however he
chose to delay his mission in favor of
staying with his new family during the
fall of shiganshina district grisha
reflects on what he must do the entire
way to the reach chapel grisham reveals
himself to be an aldian from beyond the
walls and begs free to reese to use her
founding titan ability to save
shiganjina from the titans that are
breaking in however succumbing to the
will of carl fritz she refuses to act he
is unable to bring himself to kill the
entire rhys family horrified at the
thought of killing children it is only
when aaron acting through the timeless
paths of the future demands he fulfill
his duty by reminding him of his fellow
restorationists and his dead sister faye
that grisha finally transforms grisha
easily beats frida in combat and devours
her before going on to slaughter the
entire reese family sparing only rod
reese on aaron's orders the next attack
titan we're going to talk about is of
course aaron yeager aaron was born in
shiganshina district within the southern
region of walmaria to karl jaeger and
grisha yeager during the fall of
shiganshina district aaron is sent to a
shelter for refugees from walmareia soon
after grisha arrives and finds aaron who
tells him that his mother was eaten
after hearing this grisha takes aaron to
a nearby forest and instructs him to go
to the basement before aaron can react
he is injected with titan's serum
turning him into a mindless titan aaron
instinctively eats his father receiving
his titan powers including the dormant
founding titan during the battle for
trost aaron tries to kill the titan that
ate his friend only to be incapacitated
by a second titan biting off his leg
aaron regains consciousness just in time
to save armin from being eaten being
swallowed himself in the process his
anguish triggers his first
transformation into his attack titan
form bursting out of the titan that
devoured him he proceeds to wreak havoc
on all the titans he finds this is the
first time an anime that we see the
attack titan in action aaron was later
challenged with many tasks that needed
his attack titan abilities for example
plugging the hole in wall rows as the
time went by he joined levi's squad and
hanji started doing experiments on him
but during those experiments aaron was
unable to activate his titan abilities
after the incident with a spoon with the
help of hanji's deductions aaron learns
that a titan transformation requires him
to have a clear goal in mind in addition
to self-injury throughout the anime we
see that aaron has more and more control
of his attack titan he manages to defeat
annie as well as overpower reiner in
hand-to-hand combat in season 4 when
aaron and cervicore launch an attack on
marley we get to see aaron fully in
control of his attack titan as he
transforms many times during a battle he
grew so strong that he managed to defeat
both warhammer titan and the jaw titan
with mikasa's help of course we don't
get to learn much about other attack
titans throughout history in flashback
about king fritz in the amir life we get
to see a glimpse of a first ever attack
titan it looked very different from all
other attack titans we saw in the anime
it had some very scary titan marks on
its face and long black hair as for the
others we only get to see them fighting
on aaron's founding titan during the
battle of heaven and earth where aaron
brought all the past titan shifters to
fight his friends a curly hair attack
titan can be seen atop of aaron as well
as another attack titan that looks more
like a normal human with a beard and
chest hair reminding of grisha's titan
annie is also seen battling a bald
attack titan to be honest we get to see
these titans very briefly and we only
have one picture of them so there isn't
any additional information about them
our artists drew them very well so all
of you can better see what they look
like click on this video to learn more
about all colossal titans in attack on
titan go on click it it's an amazing
video